[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me tom
heap this week in the struggle to halt
global warming we look at a promising
practical way and faltering political
will
a new carbon sucking super tree is
sprouting on our farms which can grow at
least four times faster than average
timber we'll introduce you to polonia
in the coal mining heart of america
they've had deadly floods that may have
been worsened by climate change but
making that link is uncomfortable for
local residents and their politicians
here we face uncommon drought with
hosepipe bans coming this weekend and
another heat spike forecast for next
weekend
and years of economic turmoil resulting
from fossil fuel dependence
all this comes as conservative party
members are chewing their pencils and
pondering where to put their cross
across to decide who will be the next
prime minister but in weeks of
leadership campaigning talk of climate
and the environment has been conspicuous
by its almost total absence and when
green stuff was mentioned it was mostly
to be skeptical about climate-friendly
policies
why is this and how will it affect
government decisions i hovered around at
sky's special leadership program to find
out
in a few moments time these seats will
be full of conservative party members
some of the very people who'll be
deciding who will be our next prime
minister but what interests me is to
what extent their decision is influenced
by what the contenders have had to say
about climate change
what for you the three or four most
important issues i'd like our new prime
minister to to address the borders issue
law and order look after the old a bit
more housing the nhs just want to see
them make a success of brexit the cost
of living crisis the fuel crisis none of
the members i spoke to here listed
climate or environment as one of the
issues that really mattered to them and
i guess that tells you something so for
one or two of them i decided to ask them
about it
climate policies important to you
absolutely absolutely
absolutely i appreciate how important it
is but not not in my decision making
though i don't think net zero by 2050
should come at the cost of sorting out
this whole cost of living crisis there
may be something temporarily in place
and then looking to green policies in
the future there are other problems
which i would like to see sorted longer
for them
of course and rishi sunak as well good
evening to you both we can make it more
likely that the economy grows we'll be
real liz trust please stand up the
lights on the economy are flashing red a
cynical motivation to try and get you
into number 10.
well that's the end of this special
battle for number 10 program and climate
was mentioned by kaye in discussion with
rishi sunak which gives me some stuff to
talk about with my colleagues
and those colleagues are helen ann smith
our business correspondent and thomas
mora our science correspondent
i started that debate saying i was going
to write down any time they mentioned
climber and i had a blank piece of paper
for a very long time but they did get
around to it and certainly they got
around to things to do with energy but
helen and smith what did you make of it
well it was interesting wasn't it it was
as you say climate change didn't come up
really at all for the front half of the
programme um you know from my
perspective i was surprised that there
was less conversation about energy bills
really surprised because we've had some
diabolical predictions in the last week
and every day new numbers come forward
about just how high we expect those
bills to get in the winter now in excess
of you know 3 500 pounds for an average
family that is three times what it was
last year so really really really
serious we didn't hear much that would
perhaps please people who are worried
about climate change but thomas one of
the things i think we did here which was
a surprise to me at least was rishi
sunak laying out some
thoughts if not policies about energy
savings yes i think many
environmentalists will implore applaud
him for talking about home insulation
energy efficiency and so on many people
watching are living in homes where we
can help improve the insulation loft
insulation cavity wall insulation smart
temperature controls and he did actually
say that would be 300 pound savings uh
to the the bills if you started uh
insulating people's homes and of course
that is the quickest way of reducing
energy consumption in this country and
liz trust repeated her commitment to for
a moratorium on these the green energy
levees i would also have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy level to
save people money on fuel bills how much
would that save anyone oh it's it's
really not going to be very much i mean
we're talking about roughly 150 pounds a
year so you know you put that into
context and actually i have to say
you know richie soon as slightly guilty
of this as well because his answer is to
cut vat on energy bills we're talking
about a really very small amount so it's
not gonna make a huge amount of
difference to people but it would make a
very big difference to the climate a bit
confused about that as well because that
money has to come from somewhere doesn't
i mean it's commitment legal commitment
not just to companies but you've got to
pay people on
who lower incomes from that warm home
discounts yeah absolutely so what this
is what uh
liz trust has not talked about is how
you're going to make up the uh that uh
if if it's not going to come through
bills will it come from general taxation
exactly i mean i think
the broader point is is the messaging um
and how it might undermine
uh the public's view
of of the green commitment if you start
removing it from the bill then perhaps
it's not quite so important after all
and i think that's quite dangerous a
slippery slope if you like because you
might start eroding
that belief that net zero is the way the
government is going
[Music]
so with just shy of a month until the
new pm is decided i'm intrigued to know
if contender's words on the campaign
trail will be matched by their decisions
in office joining me to chew over the
future of this government and climate
policy are baroness worthington who sits
as a cross venture in the house of lords
and helped author the climate change act
and rebecca powell a conservative mp who
was until recently an environment
minister welcome to you both thank you
so much for joining me and i come to you
first rebecca if that's okay do you
share my slight disappointment about how
little we've heard about climate change
during this campaign
well it's not for the ones of me trying
uh i've actually had
conversations in fact with both
candidates about this very thing and i
would say there's a lot of conversation
behind the scenes but it's quite
interesting isn't it uh that when we've
gone out to the hustings uh the general
public uh have asked i would say
actually yes less questions than i would
have expected there were some on sky
last night which was good and i've
certainly been asked questions when i've
gone out um two events linked to this
leadership election and because as far
as i'm concerned as the environment
minister and having worked in government
across this portfolio uh for the last
three years uh it is right up there at
the top of the agenda and linking into
the state and indeed it needs to be
forgive me rebecca the assumption is it
may be a stereotype is that the actual
electorate that they're catering to
those hundred and sixty thousand
thousand conservative members don't you
know care a huge deal about this it's
not one of their top priorities do you
think that's fair
well it's interesting because amongst
the general population it is one of
their top branches you've got cost of
living nhs and then environment and
climate change so i think it's very much
about getting that message across that
actually this is all linked to cost of
living and how we live if we can get uh
renewable energy and the program
underway and really drive that of course
what that will do is reduce uh our enemy
energy bills and make us much more
secure so it's a matter of linking those
things up
so bryony worthington i suppose that
that question i posed in the
introduction um do you think that the
kind of tone that we've heard not much
mention at all and when it has been
mentioned it's been quite skeptical
about climate-friendly policies do you
think that'll be reflected when they get
into government or are you know some
environmentalists getting their knickers
in a twist unnecessarily
i know i i think it is important that um
you listen to what these candidates are
saying they're going to be our prime
minister and uh you would expect them to
be across a brief which is you know
commensurate with that office and and
climate change is a huge significance
both domestically and internationally so
the fact that they may not be uh
speaking to those agendas with
enthusiasm does i think cause a lot of
people concern
and it would be a terrible thing for
britain to start going back on its
climate change commitments because we're
just starting to see investment flowing
the confidence amongst industry that we
are going to stick to this agenda is
really high at the moment and what we
don't want to see is lots of chopping
and changing and
signaling that we're not serious about
it because that will cost us jobs cost
us investment and it will also diminish
us on the international stage where
we've had such a strong leadership role
but when they get into office do you
think that the penny will drop famously
i think it was patrick valance sort of
took boris johnson aside and and made
him realize the importance of of climate
change might we see something there and
they might kind of be a bit more
enthusiastic about these policies
well yeah yes i hope so i mean just you
know turning to rishi sunak he's been
the chancellor for two years and he's
been chancellor during an extraordinary
period of inflation that's driven by
fossil fuel prices and yet the policies
introduced have shown no awareness at
all of what the real solutions are to
that problem so i am a little bit
concerned that he could spend two years
as chancellor not understand the gravity
of the situation of climate change and
nor understand that the problem of
inflation is also about fossil fuels and
that the solutions to both are as as
rebecca says changing the way we produce
energy so we use more of our home-grown
electricity
rebecca you've i think come out in
support of rishi sunak so given what
we've heard you must be a bit
disappointed about his pro he's what
he's had to say about climate change
he's you know not in favor of onshore
wind even when it's supported by local
communities but is in favor of fracking
when it's supported by local communities
that doesn't feel right if you're
concerned about climate change
i think actually i'd disagree with them
what we've just heard from the previous
speaker i actually think
rishi in particular really understands
climate change and he was the first one
that did come out saying of course we've
legislated the net zero by 2050 so
there's no way he'd backtrack on that i
think yeah
you know we're very questionable on this
he certainly isn't an also i actually i
think he's done a great deal to move
this agenda forward in terms of
committing to make uh the uk a net zero
finance center of the world he's done so
much on green finance and all of those
policies so that we can leverage in
outside investment and partnership
funding that's going to be absolutely
critical to driving forward this agenda
briny we are in a cost of living crisis
and uh liz trust has said she would
remove the green levees and that cuts
150 pounds potentially off people's
bills that could be a big deal for some
people who are struggling to pay their
bills couldn't it
i'm afraid that's a complete distraction
the real problem is that we've got
extraordinary energy prices at the
moment and and those are delivering
windfall profits of extraordinary levels
to the upstream oil and gas sector and
the chancellor's windfall tax
unfortunately was a good policy but he
delivered it in such a way that he is
encouraging him to spend more chasing
down fossil fuels and not using that
money to help people through this winter
when actually we need to be focusing on
keeping people safe helping people
understand how they can keep warm and it
really is truly going to be a terrible
winter ahead forgive me uh brownie we
must wrap it up there but bryony
worthington and rebecca powell thank you
very much indeed for your time
and just a reminder that you can watch
our special tory leadership program the
battle for number 10 across all of our
platforms including the sky news mobile
app and youtube well just before we take
a quick break time for one of your
questions sylvia writes in to ask about
hydrogen cars she had a friend in italy
who had one in the 1980s and the only
thing to come out of the exhaust was
water why she asks is that not a good
option here great question sylvia and
we'll answer it after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show before
the break we had a question from sylvia
on why we don't have more hydrogen cars
hydrogen-powered cars emit just water
from the exhaust pipe and their range is
greater than most electric vehicles but
currently creating the hydrogen itself
emits lots of greenhouse gases at the
production stage and the biggest
drawback is probably distribution the
great advantage of electric cars is that
we have a grid that runs to nearly every
home and business compare that to
producing a hydrogen delivery network
with tankers or pipes
but we should never shut the door on any
green tech and hydrogen power is finding
favor with trucks and construction
vehicles
and of course we'd love more questions
from you you can scan the qr code here
or go to any of our social media
accounts and put your questions in the
comments
now it is a key weekend for green
politics in america the inflation
reduction act the slightly confusing
name for a bill which focuses on climate
and energy spending is likely to pass
its most critical political political
hurdle in washington
at stake is hundreds of billions in
funding for low-carbon tech and
assistance for coal-producing states one
of which kentucky has just experienced
deadly floods and our u.s correspondent
mark stone has been there
it is little over a week since the most
devastating floods ripped through
communities in this stunning corner of
kentucky
i've never seen anything like this
we travel deep into these appalachian
valleys past rivers that were
overwhelmed
roads out
and homes gone forever you ever seen
water like this no
no
never and i've lived here my whole life
the people here are not well off and
they lost everything
it took about five minutes for that to
happen five or six minutes and it was
gone
but what about the bigger picture the
cause
climate change
possibly yes
in a place called troublesome creek we
met a man called nolan allen
he'd approached us
he'd wanted to show us what the flooding
had looked like
obviously you're scared i've never seen
the water
in my driveway that far
it's unimaginable and do you have a view
about climate change and that debate
well
i could this is coal country
the people
most of my family my friends
people i know went to school with
their livelihoods were coal based
pretty much
and uh
we can't immediately go to any other
form of energy we just we don't have the
capability it's just not as simple as
going green going electorate you can't
it is not you cannot
you can't politics is of course entwined
in all of this
kentucky is a red state climate change
skeptic donald trump won here in 2020
with a whopping 62 percent of the vote
and yet the governor is a democrat
andy beshear won his election by a
whisker thanks to support in the cities
but not so much out here
and so he must walk a fine line
we know we'll still be finding people
sadly in the days
to come
he knows how divisive the climate change
issue is three full days after the
floods he hadn't mentioned it until we
asked him listen i believe
in climate change i believe it causes
more devastating weather but my job
right now is to get families back
together get a roof over their head and
make sure they have enough to eat they
just want to find their relatives and
they don't want their experience to be
co-opted in a larger debate
eight hours drive to the east washington
dc the capital of the world's second
biggest polluting nation mr mansion here
that larger debate is front and center
but progress is hard going
remember glasgow when joe biden made
massive commitments to cut carbon
emissions well that was all based on the
cooperation of the people in there and
over the past few months
there has been gridlock the deal that
president biden hopes to sign is a
compromise but it does include loans for
electric cars to cut emissions and
crucially support for states like
kentucky tax credits totaling 30 billion
dollars to encourage domestic
manufacturing of wind turbines solar
panels and batteries
in all the biden administration says it
would slash the country's carbon
emissions by roughly 40 percent by 2030
the promises he made in glasgow within
reach
that's all very well but it's too late
for the people of troublesome creek
whose experiences now seem to be the new
normal
mark stone sky news
from some political turmoil to a
potential natural solution this modest
length of building timber holds carbon
that was captured through the leaves as
it grew as a tree a few years back it is
this capacity of woodlands to absorb co2
the principle culprit in global warming
that has made tree planting a priority
your average tree will absorb or
sequester around 22 kilograms of carbon
dioxide every year
is that a lot well on average each of us
is responsible for emitting
227 times that amount nearly 5 tons per
person per year so what if there were a
super tree that could suck up carbon
much faster
in the garden of england something is
breaking through the soil which kentish
farmer doug won still believes will be
massive my foot here to show you
something that i think is going to play
a major role in the reversal of climate
change and where is it it's right here
beneath our feet this at our feet yes
this tree this is a polonia
so it's all about speed of growth is it
because it's not wowing me with its size
right yeah it really is it will grow
from that
to
the size of a 40 year old oak
in about eight to ten years
now you've got something behind your
back there what's the point in that uh
so this is this is actually the timber
so okay this thing will grow into
something that we can cut something this
like this out of very quickly
doug's transforming his farm to be more
climate friendly while still producing
plenty of food he makes his own
fertilizer from distillery waste
coats barns in solar panels
and grows fly larvae this is currently
being heated
with electricity from the solar panels
to feed to his free-range hens
700 paulonia trees are planted in rows
across this field where cattle graze the
trees will absorb a lot of the nutrients
that the cows are depositing all over
the field
and they'll use that for their
growth so here we are tom this is a tree
that's one year older than the one we
just we've just seen over there wow that
is rapid so it's put on nearly i don't
know seven foot a couple of meters yeah
i mean that's probably a foot down down
there so that's at least eight foot tall
now and put on about sort of six and a
half feet in the first year or last year
and it's put about two-ish on this year
so far in a very dry year and roughly
how long would it take to make a tree
similar to the size of the one behind
you so uh it will be that sort of size
in about four years but give me some
figures on this in terms of carbon
capture because that's what we're all
about here drawing the carbon out of the
atmosphere absolutely so we've
calculated that these trees will average
through their 10-year life cycle 63
kilos per tree per year of carbon
sequestered into leaf matter roots and
timber and how does that compare to i
don't know conifers or other trees very
roughly it's double most other species
of tree uh compare it to a traditional
woodland plantation and it's about four
times the amount wow and could this
really be a long term carbon storage
answer yeah absolutely it's really
important to lock away the carbon you
know in this timber into buildings for
you know centuries to come and we've got
a good example we can show you over here
some funding from this project comes
from carbon offsetting where other
companies will pay doug for absorbing
emissions on their behalf
but his passion comes from locking up
carbon in buildings for the long term he
gave me a history lesson from his
ancient barn within this timber is
embedded
ceo's atmospheric co2 from the 15th
century and before
and it really is our our vision that we
start to use this timber polonia timber
to do exactly the same thing in the 21st
century sequester 21st century co2 into
construction materials to build the
buildings of the future
once considered just botanical exotics
paolonia trees could combine storing
carbon for everyone with banking some
income for farmers
while doug is mixing trees with grazing
over in suffolk on the houston estate
they have dedicated 200 hectares to
paulownia and planted a hundred and
sixteen thousand saplings they went in
the ground earlier this summer and as a
non-native species they had to undergo
rigorous examination from forestry
england to check out the environmental
impact they got the all clear and other
landowners are expected to plant
hundreds more hectares next year so
paulownia in a future top 10 list of
baby names what do you think
and finally do you want to see a nudie
branch
thought so
ta-da
nudi branch is the group name for sea
slugs and this extraordinarily jolly
specimen just two centimeters long has
been spotted for the first time in uk
waters it should be addressed as
babakina
and can be seen near an uninhabited rock
by the isles of silly it truly is a
beautiful world
bye
[Music]
you